It is maddening to be reminded to appreciate
what we have:
for someone to tell us we shouldn’t forget
to be grateful.
It’s in conflict with our times, and their
emphasis on constant ambition and striving.
The idea of pausing to take stock of what
has gone well, to be content with many things
as they are - this feels strange and dangerous,
like some kind of a loser’s counsel - or
the consolation prize.
But in truth, there is so much that, if we
learnt we might be dead by nightfall, we would
promptly remember to value:
the summer night sky
the taste of cold milk
old brick walls
deserted railway stations
the presence of our partners beside us in
the stillness of dawn.
We are ungrateful partly out of a fear; a
fear of accepting what we have – as if to
pause to appreciate things as they are might
make us ‘soft’, complacent, without the
will-power to take on new challenges.
Anxiety feels so much more natural.
It’s been with us from the start.
But ultimately, it's not heroic or sensible
always to be dissatisfied; relentlessly to
focus on everything that's gone wrong and
to obsess about our humiliations and rejections.
There's in truth far more courage and skill
in being able to identify a hopeful perspective:
in knowing how to train and keep our eyes
on what’s been - more or less - OK.
What can best help us in this is - oddly - is the
thought of our own death: how soon and how
unexpectedly it may come, and how much we'll
miss about life when it does.
We are constantly undermined by our failure
to retain the purity and drama of this helpfully
morbid insight – which should strike us
once every day at least
and to put it to powerful use in the ordinary course of
life.
Gratitude is the dividend due to us when,
for a few moments, we begin to assess our
lives with a truer sense of all our small
but significant advantages - and with a frank,
humble recognition of all we have to lose
- and one day will.